They are elementary things.
Actually, I'll deal with terminology,
but in my opinion, halachic
terminology is very important
and each term expresses an idea.
And I'm going to deal with the terminology
centered around Jewish holidays and
I'll try -- I mean, to somehow to
-- to follow, I mean, the lead
of terminology and to analyze
the very essence of Jewish holidays.
It is a strange -- or shall I say
paper that I sat down to write.
I had something else in
mind, not to debate here.
What came into this
world is a different one,
but I believe that you'll follow
me and it will help you, I mean,
in understanding the Jewish
philosophy of holidays.
When we speak of festivals, we
must distinguish between two terms.
One term is yom kadosh, or the
way people in their halachic
lingo say kedushat hayom.
The difference is that with yom
kadosh, is a kadosh an adjective?
When you say kedushat hayom,
is the kedushah substantive?
Well, this one group of holidays which can
be described as yom kadosh,
or yamim kedoshim, or those
who possess kedushat hayom.
There is another group of holidays which
we call or we classify as
Yom Tov or yamim tovim.
Both terms, that of kedushat
hayom and that of the Yom
Tov, are of biblical origin.
They are certainly of
Talmudic origin as well.
Kedushat hayom, the whole
concept of kedushat hayom, there
are days which are endowed with holiness.
Usually, when we speak about days,
I mean, we never think of something
substantive, of something having
a content, an essence in it.
In philosophy, we call
it sensia, substantia.
To us, time is not something living.
It's not
a subject to which attributes can be
ascribed and traits, actually, predicated.
To us, time is like -- in the Kantian
manner is just -- it is actually a
mathematical concept, nothing else.
Now matter and physics have
combined time with space, so it
is empty, as empty as space is.
It is just one of the coordinate
system -- it's one coordinate of a system
within which we try to explain the world
-- I mean, the cosmic dynamics.
Judaism time was something else,
was some -- a living entity.
There was substance to time.
There was individuality to time.
There was essence to time and
you could ascribe attributes to
time in the same manner as you
do ascribe attributes to people.
That’s a nice person, a good person,
a handsom person,
a holy person or an evil person.
And all this speaks of time, holy
time, holy day, an evil day, a sad day.
We actually, as a matter of fact,
in our colloquial we use in all
languages, even Yiddish and German
and any language, an evil day.
But while, I mean, modern man
thinks that an evil day means
a day on which evil -- somehow
an evil event took place.
In Yahadus, say arur hayom, it
means the day itself is cursed and
the same applies to positive attributes.
When we say holy day, it means the
day itself is holy, not a day in which
man somehow experiences holiness.
No, this already rationalization.
I mean, when we approach Yahadus, we
should, many time, try to understand
Yahadus in its own categories.
Whether they appear fresh and new
to us or perhaps old-fashioned
is completely irrelevant, but we
have to understand Yahadus in its
unique singular categories
and time in Yahadus
is something substantive, something -- essential.
It is an individuality.
I would even say it's a personality.
This is not just a part of a
mathematical coordinate system.
So hence, the pasuk says,
"Vayevarech Elokim es yom ha'shevi'i
va'yekadesh oso," God has blessed
the seventh day and hallowed it.
In Nechemiah, we find
that on Rosh Hashanah and Ezra recited
the law and the people cried,
so "V'ha'Levi'im machshim ha'am," and the
Levites tried to silence the people,
saying that it is forbidden to cry on
Rosh Hashanah,
that they described the
day, the character on the day,
"Ki kadosh hayom l'Adoneinu," the
day is holy and dedicated to God.
The term Yom Tov is also mentioned
in the Bible, namely where?
Where?
Yom tov in the Bible?
In Megillah, correct.
In the Scroll of Esther, "Osim es
yom arbaah asar l'chodesh
Adar simchah u'mishteh v'yom tov."
Of course, we, in our halachic
lingo, use both terms continually.
Sometimes, we
speak about kedushas hayom and
sometimes, we speak about Yom Tov.
Quite often, we don't discriminate
between these two terms.
Remarkable is one detail, why we apply
the epithet of Yom Tov to all
holidays without any discrimination.
We call Pesach Yom Tov, we call Shavuos
Yom Tov, Rosh Hashanah Yom Tov, even
Yom Kippur we call Yom Tov, and Sukkos.
We have never said about
Shabbos that it's a Yom Tov.
Never.
Shabbos v'Yom Tov
I mean, if it's two extremes, two
poles, and man somehow swings like a
pendulum between those two poles, but you
have never found, we have come across in
it, in our halachic literature or in the
Bible, I mean, or in any commentary that
Shabbos be called and termed Yom Tov.
Apparently, Shabbos is not Yom Tov.
Why?
But in a way, we have
been dealing now with
the kedushat hayom,
with yamim kedoshim,
but for instance, Chanukah or Purim
are Yamim Tovim mi'd'Rabbanan, yet
they do not possess kedushat hayom.
They are not yamim kedoshim.
Concerning Purim, we have already pointed
out the description of the day as Yom Tov
is mentioned in the Megillah.
As regards Chanukah and, of
course, Chanukah is not mentioned
in the kisvei ha'kodesh.
There is no Megillas Chanukah in
kisvei ha'kodesh, so we have to
simply to refer to Megillas Taanit.
In Megillas Taanit, quoted by the
Gemara in Shabbos, Daf Chaf-Alef, I
believe, Amud Beis, the Braisa states,
"L'shanah ha'ba asa'um yom tov b'hallel
v'hoda'a o' b'simchah u'v'hallel," so
the name Yom Tov
is applicable to Chanukah, too.
However, as
we mentioned, they lack kedushas hayom,
while Shabbos and Gimmel Regalim and
Rosh Hashanah and Yom Kippur
are yamim kedoshim, Chanukah
and Purim are yemei chol.
Now, let me ask a simple question.
What does kedushas hayom mean?
What is it, actually?
(Audience member) Issur melachah.
Correct.
When we say that the
day is holy, "Ki kodesh
hayom l'Adoneinu," what does
it mean in halachic terms?
What kedushas hayom means at the very
outset is simply -- kedushas hayom denotes
or signifies an inherent endowment.
This I told you before, or shall I say
it is a -- now it has become a colloquial
term, a charisma enmeshed or hidden in
the very substance or essence of the day.
And this charisma, this inner quality,
it's a mysterious quality which
is hidden in the very essence of the
day, expresses itself halachically as
it was said here in issur melachah,
prohibition against work.
Chanukah and Purim do not
precipitate issur melachah.
Apparently, they lack that
specific endowment which usually
expresses itself in issur melachah.
Wherever there is no issur melachah,
one cannot speak of kedushas hayom.
The latter is inseparable from the
idea of absolute rest, but not so
much rest as absolute cessation or
complete stoppage, discontinuation.
I mean, all right, it's easy
to say that the kedushas hayom
expresses itself in issur melachah.
I mean,
could somebody prove it
here by quoting a text?
We say b'Retzei in Birkas Hamazon,
"Ki yom zeh gadol v'kadosh", "lishbas
bo v'lanuach bo b'ahavah k'mitzvas
retzonecha," for this is a great
and holy day dedicated
lishbos bo, to cessation or
discontinuation and to rest, of course,
with law in accordance with thy will.
Apparently, the adjectives
gadol v'kadosh are
linked up, inseparably linked
up with shevisah and menuchah.
And there is no doubt that shevisah is by
far a more important attribute of the day
than menuchah, leaving off and resting.
Now, let's not forget that the term
kedushah quite often in the Bible has the
connotation of separateness,
of being separate,
or it has the meaning of
being not common or a meaning of
uncommonness, singularity,
distinctiveness.
As a matter of fact, the term
kodesh also has the connotation of
distance, of being remote,
being far, far away.
When we say, "Kadosh Kadosh Kadosh
Havayah Tzevakos melo chol ha'aretz  kevodo,"
so you indicate this great paradox in our religious experience,
that on the one hand, to experience God as remote,
as distant, as abiding in infinity, in the recesses of transcendence,
and on the other hand,
God is my companion, right here.
"Kadosh Kadosh Kadosh," remote,
exalted, above and beyond everything,
above and beyond the cosmos, the
great -- the boundless universe
and the same time, "melo chol ha'aretz
kevodo," I mean, He fills out the universe
and He's right here near me.
That's why Chabad, the two terms, mimalei kol almin v'sovev kol almin are so important.
So, basically, kedushah means many times distance,
remoteness, being unreachable.
Therefore, when we say Shabbosos
v'Yamim Tovim, that they're being
set aside as days of rest and
discontinuation or leaving off or
cessation, are not ordinary, common days.
Whoever possesses kedushah cannot be a
common entity, cannot be a common person.
There is something unique about him,
something singular, something different.
So if Shabbosos v'Yamim Tovim are
endowed with kedushah, it means
that endowed with uniqueness.
They are many times remote
from the ordinary way of
life or from ordinary days.
They are not ordinary;
they're not common days.
They are -- what shall I use
the term -- they are freaks.
They're different.
You know very well, sometimes
you may admire a freak and
sometimes, he's very annoying.
A freak can be very annoying.
So Shabbos and Yom Tov can be
terribly annoying,
annoying and
interfering with our everyday
conveniences and little pleasures.
It's exactly the -- what shall I say?
This reflects exactly kedushah.
Even -- Yahadus as such
is sometimes very annoying and
very unwelcome to the ordinary man.
They're unusual days.
What happens on that day?
Nothing in particular, just
the world today, its routine
is interrupted on that day.
What happens on that day?
The established program of human
activities -- what is that program?
What does that -- where is this
program mentioned in the Bible?
The human being has a certain
routine, a certain program.
This program has
not changed over the
centuries and millennia.
It's the same.
The program, in my opinion, and you
will find yes, correct, I believe it's beautifully-
described in Barchi Nafshi.
"Tizrach ha'shemesh -- ha'shemesh
yei'aseifun v'el me'onosam yirbatzum.
Yeitzei adam lefaalo v'laavodaso
adei arev."
The sun rises, they slink away,
the young lions,
and they hide in their dens.
Man goes forth unto his work and
to his labor
until the evening.
That routine of yizrach ha'shemesh yeitzei
adam lefaalo v'laavodaso adei arev, and
that monotony is discontinued if ba'yom
is not an ordinary day
but a yom gadol v'kadosh,
a great day and a holy day.
Of course, even on a yom gadol
v'kadosh, the sun rises.
The universe is not different, certainly
the young lions crouch in their dens,
on a yom gadol v'kadosh,
but man does not
go forth unto his work or to his labor.
No.
Today, man has a different,
a unique schedule.
What the schedule is, we don't know.
This distinctiveness,
as far as the schedule is
concerned, the change
sanctifies and hallows the day
and makes it a yom gadol v'kadosh.
Why is it a yom gadol v'kadosh?
Because it is a unique day.
The question arises, what is
the nature and the essence not
of a yom gadol v'kadosh,
but of yom tov
That is deprived of kedushas hayom?
Chanukah and Purim are
deprived of kedushas hayom.
They are stripped of kedushas
hayom, melachah is permissible.
On the one hand, the day of
Chanukah or Purim, it does not
differ from the ordinary day.
On Chanukah, Purim, man goes forth with
work and to his labor until
the evening.
On the other hand,
man is called to act or to engage
with specific action, which the halacha
calls mitzvos hayom on those days.
For instance, on Purim, a man is
obligated to recite the Megillah;
on Chanukah, to light the candles, to say
Hallel, to abstain from
hesped v'taanis, from fasting
and public mourning.
The conclusion is obvious.
Even Chanukah and Purim are endowed
with some charisma,
with some singular
quality not to be found
in an ordinary day.
Of course, they are not yamim
kedoshim, yet they are -- and this
is my turn -- yamim tovim, of course,
but I would say yamim kevu'im.
They're being singled
out or yamim muvcharim.
They have been selected.
Out of 365 days, eight
days of Chanukah and one
or two days of Purim
have been selected and set apart.
Then, they are also different.
There is somehow individuality.
There is character to them.
Yet it's obvious
that they are not ordinary days.
So if this be so, so the question arises,
what is the difference between yamim
kedoshim or yamim tovim
or rather not to -- because, to
avoid confusion, I'll call it
yamim kevu'im or yamim muvcharim.
What's the difference?
Of course, the halachic answer is clear.
Yamim kedoshim are workless days, yamim kevu'im are workdays,
yet one asks,
what is the root of this distinction?
Apparently, there's a different experience
related to yamim kedoshim than the
experience which is associated with yamim
kevu'im like Chanukah and Purim.
The answer that yamim kedoshim
are all mi'd'Oraisa, of Biblical
origin, and yamim kevu'im are of
Rabbinical origin, I mean, it would
not -- simply, it would not satisfy us.
Let me give you
the answer in one sentence and
then I'll elaborate this sentence.
That's exactly what the
paper is out to accomplish.
The answer, I believe, is as follows.
The idea of yamim kedoshim or the
charisma of yamim kedoshim, expresses
itself in human -- what
shall I say -- introspection
or withdrawal.
The experience of yamim kedoshim -- of
yamim kevu'im manifests itself in human
openness and to outer directedness.
I'll elaborate that.
Let me explain it.
Wherever the Torah spoke of Shabbos,
not only of Shabbos, of the three
holidays as well, when we -- Gimmel
Regalim, Rosh Hashanah, Purim and -- Rosh
Hashanah, I mean, Pesach, Shavuos and the
Regalim, as well as Rosh Hashanah.
Wherever the Torah spoke of
Shabbos, of all the holidays,
it never failed to mention that the
day, the charismatic, the holy day, not
holiday, but the holy day is related and
dedicated to the law, to the Almighty.
"V'yom ha'shevi'i Shabbat
la'Adoshem Elokecha."
"Sheshes yamim taavod v'asisa kol
melach'techa. V'yom ha'shevi'i Shabbos
la'Adoshem Elokecha." The seventh
day is a Shabbath unto the Lord.
"Chag ha'Sukkos taaseh lach", "Shivas
yamim tachog la'Adoshem Elokecha,"
a feast of Sukkot, you'll observe
the feast of Sukkot and you'll
celebrate seven days unto the Lord.
"Chag Shavuos taaseh la'Adoshem
Elokecha," the Feast of Weeks
you will celebrate unto the Lord.
What does it mean?
What does it mean, the
word la'Adoshem Elokecha?
What do the words
"The seventh day is a
Shabbath unto the Lord" mean?
What idea hides behind those strange,
enigmatic words
"unto the Lord thy God"?
It would've been sufficient if He had
said, "Sheshes yamim taavod v'asisa kol
melachtecha. V'yom ha'shevi'i Shabbat."
The idea would've been conveyed to us.
The six days you're allowed to work; and
the seventh day, we have to cease to work.
I believe that those
enigmatic words express an
exalted idea in Yahadus.
I would say it is the idea which was
mentioned by the Eitz HaChaim, the A"RI,
I mean, the founder of the Lurianic
School in mysticism and later developed
and made the central idea of Chabad by the Tanya, by the founder of Chabad.
The idea, what
is known, whoever studied it, as
sod ha'tzimtzum, the mystery of
self-contraction or the mystery
of self-limitation or the mystery
of self-restriction or the
mystery of withdrawal and retreat.
As a matter of fact,
this mystery has accumulated also
the controversy between Chassidim and
Misnagdim, if we consider this controversy
from a philosophical viewpoint.
What is this mystery of tzimtzum say?
I mean, you know, let me
explain it in very simple terms.
The mystery of tzimtzum says
that creation of the world is a
sacrificial act on the part
of the Almighty,
as if, kaviyachol, the
Almighty has brought a sacrifice.
He gave something up when He
said, "Yehi ohr," let there be light
or by saying yehi ohr, the Almighty meant, let there be a world.
Before the universe came into existence,
God was one, His name was one.
By creating a world,
in general, and by creating
man, in particular, God
had surrendered His
aloneness, of being alone
and His loneliness, again, of
being alone, to the world.
In order to create the world,
He allowed finiteness, in
this case, a physical world,
a physical universe to share in His
infinite being, in His infinite existence.
He allowed
somebody else, or something else,
to share with Him in what was exclusively
His own.
Prior to creation, where there was
only one infinite, all-inclusive
and all-encompassing, and
all-embracing existence, God,
there was nothing beside Him.
God did, kaviyachol, to withdraw and
to contract Himself in order to permit
a world to be born out of nothingness.
Yetzira means an act of self-restricting
on the part of infinity
and permitting
finitude to exist beside infinity,
something which is nonsensical
from the viewpoint of logic.
From the viewpoint of logic, you all know
that if you should take an infinite number
and you try to add a finite
number to the infinite number,
what will you get in sum total?
An infinite number.
So basically, the whole existence of the
world is an absurdity from one viewpoint.
It's nonsensical, we really don't exist.
But how can finitude
exist beside infinity?
It's mathematically wrong.
It's logically wrong.
And this absurdity
is responsible for our existence,
that the world came into existence.
This is the great mystery of tzimtzum.
I cannot develop it, I mean,
fully, in accordance with the
Lurianic doctrine, which was developed,
I mean, later by the founder of Chabad.
It is true
that in particular,
the creation of man in God's
image was a sacrificial act on
the part of Hakadosh Baruch Hu.
The mere fact that He endowed
man with imago dei, with the
image -- with His image, this itself
already an act of giving up
because there is somebody
who is divine.
And He endowed man not only with the
image, but He endowed both with great
talents, with extraordinary capabilities.
These numerous skills
got bestowed upon him, honor and
glory which belong exclusively to God.
It's very interesting, Chassidim
do it every Shabbos, but in my
opinion, it is more impressive,
the custom of Misnagdim
is far more impressive.
We say it only once a year.
What I'm referring to?
"Haadares v'ha'emunah l'chai olamim.
Ha'binah v'ha'brachah l'chai olamim.
Ha'hod v'he'hadar l'chai olamim." With all those attributes, actually
belong -- still belong exclusively to
God, but God, in His generosity, has
bestowed some of the attributes on man.
Man is productive.
Indeed, he's a creative being.
God allowed man to consider himself
master and lord of his environment.
"Kol shatah tachas raglav," He
put everything under his feet.
God was generous with man.
He even urged man to explore the
universe, "Urdu ba'aretz v'chivshu'ha,"
and He advised him to reach out,
even for the boundless and the
fantastic, even for that which
is unreachable.
And man, regretfully, many times,
is mistaken and he actually looks
upon himself as if he were a
creator, as if he indeed owned
everything, himself and the world.
What do you call in
Kabbalah the nachash ha'kadmoni?
The serpent of old or the ancient serpent.
The ancient serpent of Genesis
suggested to man that he may conquer
the world and crown himself as God.
God tolerates it.
God does not take away man's skills, man's
talents, man's capabilities, even though
from time to time, man misuses them and
becomes arrogant and also very foolish.
On the Shabbat,
and on every yom
gadol v'kadosh, when a great day
when a holy day
arrives,
man is called upon to seize, not to rest.
Rest is the result, but he's
called upon to seize.
What should he seize?
What?
What activity?
What activity should he seize?
To play the role of master and lord,
to acknowledge that he
possesses nothing,
owns nothing, masters nothing
and he is nothing.
That he's not in control,
certainly, that he's neither in control
of the world, nor is he in control of himself.
Or of his own talents and skills.
Yom kadosh is not so much
a day of rest, of menuchah.
It is mainly a day of shevisa, of
stopping discontinuing.
Give it up.
And while menuchah
denotes rest, shevisa has the connotation
of leaving off, of discontinuing,
something which one is accustomed to.
But what is this something?
What is this something?
Mainly this is avodah, this is work.
Why?
Why was work chosen as the means of
man's humbling himself and admitting
the truth
and, sad to say, and
pleading guilty of arrogance, of
false pretenses, of an
overexaggerated notion of himself?
Why was work chosen by the
Torah as the symbol of that
basic change in man which
should take place on a
yom gadol v'kadosh?
For two reasons.
Work, basically, is important
for two reasons.
Work is the source of
human power and glory.
No other creature is basically a
working being, a working creature.
No other creature is capable
of constructing work.
If the animal, sometimes, is busy,
but whatever the animal does is
not work in a philosophical sense.
It is pushed by some mechanical instinct.
There is no intention,
there is no plan and
there is no productivity to it.
[audio gap] -- the animal doesn't produce.
It certainly, there is no creativity.
An animal doesn't create.
Only man is a working being and
understands like that, a productive
being, and through work and
only through work, man
manifests his unlimited power.
"Va'techasreihu m'at mei'Elokim," he's
just a little bit below the angels.
The reason is because man
has a capacity for work.
Or when, for instance, in Greek mythology
and it spilled over into Greek philosophy,
into Plato's Ideal Republic, considered
work as a degrading occupation for man.
On the contrary, they always dreamt
of the golden age, or an existence
which would not require the work of man
because work which was good for
slaves -- don't forget the Greeks
had a slave society, but for
the free man, for the Hellen,
for the aristocracies, work is degrading.
It's below their dignity.
Yahadus came out, first of all, that
work is dignifying, redeeming, cleansing.
Who works?
Even, kaviyachol, God.
"Mi'kol melach'to asher asah."
And if man wants to reach dignity,
greatness, sweep, and depth, there is
only one means which he can employ.
This is work.
Work, there's another aspect to work.
Work is the cohesive force which
unites individuals into a group,
sociologically very important.
Work is the most potent factor which pulls
man out of his hideout, of his hiding, and
merges individuals into communities.
And it's a simple reason here.
Everybody knows it.
One cannot acquire all skills which
are indispensable for the gratification
of man's needs.
And therefore,
one must exchange services
with his contemporaries.
The exchange of services brings about
interdependence and interaction which,
in turn, leads to fraternization or
to the coalescence of
individuals into one entity.
Call it community, call it
society, call it state, I mean,
the name is completely irrelevant.
The constant trading and exchanging
interweaves the individual into
community and the isolated "I" into
the texture of a together existence or
an existence in community.
In short, the role which work plays
in promoting a together existence or
a community existence is tremendous.
If people didn't have to work,
if people didn't work, they would
never form a community or a state.
They would never coalesce
and unite into groups because each
individual would feel happy in his
isolation and in his place of hiding.
There wouldn't have been, I mean,
this magnetic force which pulls the
individual toward the community.
As a matter of fact, here, Yahadus,
again, is in conflict with the
philosophy of the Age of Reason.
Philosophy of the Age of Reason
adored the individual, did not
understand the community, for in
explaining the community, they had
to introduce a new concept like
the social contract which is very
artificial and very synthetic over here.
Because to Rousseau and
Montesquieu, Voltaire,
I mean, all the philosophers of
the Age of Reason, I mean,
there was basically the
individual is the great being.
Not the communities.
That's why such a story -- the
story of Robinson Crusoe was
born during the Age of Reason.
It couldn't have been born now.
with Marxism rampant and communism,
I mean, expanding quickly because
in Marxism, the individual means
nothing, the community reigns supreme.
Yahadus has never agreed with this
theory that the individual can get along
all by himself, alone on an island.
Yahadus was of the opinion that lonely man
cannot meet the task that
has been assigned to him by
his creator.
What task has been assigned
to man by his creator?
"L'avdah u'l'shamrah," to dress and
to keep, to work and to cultivate.
Working man, this man cannot
afford to be idle,
but he's got to be a working
being, so he needs a helper.
"Lo tov heyos ha'adam levado
e'eseh lo eizer kenegdo," it's
not good for him to be alone, I
shall make a helper opposite him.
In short, working man is always what
we call it in halachic
literature a reshus ha'rabim.
He's on the highway, manufacturing,
trading, exchanging goods and
services, talking, arguing, fighting,
helping, but always with somebody.
No wonder that Chava was created the
very instant Adam was charged with
the task of l'avdah u'l'shamrah.
He was placed in the Garden of Eden,
charged with the task of l'avdah
u'l'shamrah, to be a working being and
also, I mean -- and as a working being,
he needed help, so Eve was created.
No wonder I see it every day.
Perhaps that's the reason that I'm
still active, that people retire
from business or from profession,
find out and quite quickly, very
fast, that they are unneeded, lonely,
and that society abandoned them,
including their own children.
And that the world passes them by.
Because if a man stops working,
there is no need for him to
maintain communication lines with
the community, with the society.
Somehow, he expels himself.
Instantly he expels himself.
He excludes himself from
the working community.
If there is no work, there
are no responsibilities.
The communal ties, little by
little, disappear, are broken.
And on the Shabbat, God
told man to stop working.
What did He want to achieve by that?
What was God out to achieve by
telling man to stop working?
He told man to cease to work, to
leave up in the middle, retreat
and rest.
In other words, man is supposed -- but
I want you not to misunderstand me --
on Shabbos, to leave society.
Man retreats while using a bigger
term from the thou existence -- it
means I am thou existence
-- into an I existence, I existence.
He retreats on the Shabbat -- this
is the experience of the Shabbat
-- into privacy and aloneness.
On the Shabbat, the individual
gains supremacy over
the community.
He withdraws from conquest and
acquisition, from work, and if he
withdraws from conquest and acquisition
and work, then he also withdraws
from his coworkers and
partners and associates
into the mysterious abode
of an I, of a lonely I existence.
It's quite remarkable that, in
Beshalach, when Moses revealed on
behalf of the Almighty the mystery of
Shabbos to the people, so the slogan
of Shabbos then became "Al yeitzei"
-- "Sh'vu tach'techem," sit
-- stay in your places, "al yeitzei ish
mimkomo ba'yom ha'shevi'i," no man go
out of his place on the seventh day.
No fraternization.
No unitedness, I would
say, no coalescence.
Man is alone.
And he should experience
himself as a being alone.
On the Shabbat, God
tolerates no competition.
He does not want to share man
with anybody else, with society.
Hence, He told man, retreat from society.
The latter has no claims on him -- "V'yom ha'shevi'i" -- now
we understand the words.
"V'yom ha'shevi'i Shabbat la'Adoshem
Elokecha," the seventh day
is up to the Lord.
The seventh day is the
Shabbat unto thy God.
Everything belongs to Him.
Cease to be a slave to thy work,
discontinue being a servant to
society, be exclusively mine.
On Shabbat, the idea of
Shabbat is man's aloneness.
If man is alone, he's also with God.
The kedushat ha'Shabbat, the charisma
of Shabbos, expresses itself in the
returning of man to God and to himself.
In the severance of the individual from
the working society, that act
of severing hallows the day and
renders it a yom gadol v'kadosh.
Separation from society is ipso facto
liberating, liberation from society.
Man terminates his transient relations
with his fellow man and establishes
another relation, which is
permanent communion with God.
Don't ask me
any questions about it.
Of course, people do a lot of
visiting on Shabbos.
And the impression which is conveyed as if
Shabbos were a day of socializing, of
fraternizing, of being together,
it's not true.
And perhaps, I'll explain to you
later in what -- there's only
one exception to the rule, which
the Torah made, of man being alone on
Shabbos and -- that's as far as
study is concerned.
If I have time, I'll explain it.
However, let's continue.
However, Judaism thought -- here
we come to the dialectical
nature of Judaica approach.
However, Judaism thought highly
of existence in community as well.
God is not only the father of the
individuals, "Elokei Avraham Elokei
Yitzchak v'Elokei Yaakov," but
of the community, as an entity.
He's "Elokei Yisrael" as well.
Judaism's approach to
the millennial problem,
which came up in the pre-Socratic
Greek philosophy, the
problem of individual versus community.
Let me use a Talmudic phrase, "Hei
minayhu adif," which is preferred,
an individual existence or
a communal existence?
The approach of Judaism was one of
dialectics, the dialectical approach.
Namely, Judaism has accepted, as
in many other cases, accepted the
thesis as well as the antithesis.
Judaism says
as follows about this problem.
On the one hand, if man is completely
united with the community, wholly
in reshus ha'rabim, immersed
in the concerns of the many
and not paying attention to
his own needs or to himself.
I don't mean in a selfish,
in an egotistic manner.
He's liable to lose his very power,
his very humanity, his original
trust and sensitivity, the fantastic
resources of human creativity.
Ah, and man communed about it to be found
not in public man but in private man.
Not in man's communion with
others but in man's communion
with himself.
The greatness, the genius in man is to
be discovered in the monologue, not in
the dialogue between the I and the thou.
The greatness is found
in soliloquy, not in chitchat.
In his loneliness awareness and sense
of singleness, being single --
I don't mean single and not married.
I mean single that no one else is like me.
This is basic.
Chazal developed it, k'shem
sh'partzufeihem meshunos
kach daasei'hem meshunos.
Chazal did
not believe in doubles as far
as the countenance is concerned,
as the face is concerned.
They also believe that each
individual is a freak, spiritually.
He has his own unique approach,
his own unique outlook on life,
his own unique philosophy.
If two people agree, it's
because they comprise.
They give up.
Because if man were stubborn and truthful,
truthful to himself, there would be a
bellum omnes contra omnes, is upset.
The war of everybody against everybody.
There is an element of sheker, of
untruth, in human agreement, in
agreement with two individuals.
Of course, this means carrying the
theory of individualism into an
extreme, but I'm convinced that the
greatness of man is to be found in
reshus ha'yachid, in the four cubits
of his individualistic lonely existence.
The corporate state, the socialist or
communist society, tries hard to level
off the distinctiveness of individuality.
By so trying, the Marxist or
communist society destroys the very
sensitivity and creativity of man.
It's a fact.
For instance, Russia was
famous for its literature.
Russian literature, actually,
in the 19th century,
perhaps was the most profound
and the most sensitive literature.
It transcended the French
and certainly the Germans, as
far as the novel is concerned.
I'm not speaking about poetry.
As far as the novel is
concerned, it dried up.
This literature dried
up with the advent of communism in Russia.
And don't tell me because
the Russians don't allow.
Even the books which were printed,
I mean published abroad, outside of
Russia, are not great artistic works.
I mean, one got a Nobel Prize for it.
It was purely for political reasons.
The Kremlin was right as
far as the Nobel Prize
was concerned.
Couldn't compare that with
Dostoevsky, Tolstoy or Turgenev.
I mean, you couldn't compare it.
There's no sweep, there
is no depth to it.
It lacks the mysterious quality,
I mean, which Russian literature
had, because the corporate state
cannot produce sensitive souls.
Of course, you pay the toll of
the road, the artist is the first
one to pay the toll of the road.
Then comes the scientists, but the
artist, in a corporate state pays
the toll of the road, not because
the state is not liberal enough.
Simply, the resources
of creativity dry up.
They are
to be found only in an individual
who rebels against society, an
individual who has the guts to
say to society what he thinks.
The individual who is introspective, the
individual who tries to find out who he is.
And thinks the mere question,
who am I, is forbidden in Russia,
it's heresy, so if you don't answer
the question, who am I, so there
is no need for literature.
The literature is concerned
with one question.
Since Homer and what shall I say -- is
about what the human being is, who he
is and particularly who am I and what do
I stand for.
Yahadus
encouraged man
to rebel quite often against
society, to act like an individual
and to be different and unique.
No one who didn't study halachah
properly has any idea -- can imagine
how much freedom the halachic
scholar has in interpreting halachah,
in so-called chiddushim, in being
creative in the halachic field.
I mean, Yahadus has encroached.
I mean, the famous story of Rabbi
Eliezer, he was in controversy with
his colleagues and they stood up
and they counted and accepted, I
mean, the opinion of the majority.
And then, I mean, there was intervention
even on part of the Almighty
in favor Rabbi Eliezer and they
did not accept this intervention.
It shows how much freedom
the halachic scholar has.
Of course, if he's a
scholar, I want you to know.
Those who claim freedom and say the
halachah is not free are not scholars.
This is the trouble, you see.
But a scholar enjoys unlimited freedom
because the individual is the creative
agent in halachah, as well in many
other fields, and that's why you
cannot limit his freedom, I mean,
his authority to express opinions,
I mean, the way he understands.
God created just one man, Adam.
He concluded his covenant just
with one individual, Abraham.
The first redeemer was a lonely individual, Moses,
and very strange.
And while the Tablets, given to the
entire community the first time,
were quickly shattered,
the Second Luchot, the
Second Tablets, entrusted
to Moses alone, as an individual,
"V'ish al yeira b'chol ha'har ha'hu,"
no one could accompany Moses up
the mount, are still existent and
they still are committed to them.
That means Yahadus understood
very well the greatness of the
individual, and in order to be
creative, he should not be completely
immersed in society.
On the other hand, Yahadus said
complete immersion in oneself leads
to serious emotional problems.
I'm not a psychiatrist, so I can't tell
you what kind of problems there are.
I know just there are problems.
And egocentricity is not only amoral
but also a personalistic anomaly,
and that's why to say the individual
reigns supreme is impossible.
This was
the thesis.
Now, I'm trying to develop the antithesis.
Moreover, the basic virtues which
are at the apex of our ethical
hierarchy, like compassion, love,
I mean, sharing in one's travail
and distress, those basic
virtues, they're right from the
midas ha'chessed, from chessed, and
they lose their significance should
the individual live in isolation.
Robinson Crusoe could
not practice compassion.
He had no one to sympathize with.
He could not love anybody.
He could love only one person, himself.
How can the individual who withdrew
from society experience compassion
and love for his fellow man?
How can the individual love his fellow man
if he's emotionally remote from him?
And such an individual is
portrayed in the Bible.
Where?
One individual was punished and then
he learned how to live in community.
He was restored to his own
glory -- to his previous glory.
Who?
(audience member) Aharon.
No.
(audience member) Yonah.
No, no, Yonah, no.
Job.
Just a minute.
What kind of a fellow was Job?
Chazal were never sure about him.
He's a very elusive character, Job.
Chazal were not too sure.
They didn't even know when
he existed, when he lived.
One said he lived during the time
of Abraham, another one said during
the time of Moses, another one said
he lived during the time of David,
the fourth one said he lived during
the time of Mordechai v'Esther.
Anyway, I don't know when he lived,
but he didn't leave any marks.
He disappeared tracelessly,
Job, and he did not -- when
Abraham was engaged in a struggle.
Chazal speak about Abraham as the lonely
person, the whole world on one side of
the river and he on the other
side of the river.
It's quite characteristic
of Yisrael now, yeah.
But anyway, Abraham could use,
I mean, the help and assistance
of such a powerful man as Job.
Did Job help him?
No, not at all.
He was not concerned.
The same, Moses could've used him, too.
According to one interpretation, he was
a member of the inner council of the
chicken cabinet -- of the kitchen cabinet.
Of the kitchen cabinet.
It's either chicken cabinet
or kitchen cabinet, what?
Of that conferring cabinet,
you see, which has decided the
destiny of the Jew in Mitzrayim.
"Kol ha'ben ha'yilod
ha'ye'orah tashlichuhu." What
he did?
Balaam was educated -- I mean,
he had recommended "Kol ha'ben
ha'ye'orah tashlichuhu."
Yisro opposed this opinion.
It's a little too primitive.
It's primitive, you don't do such things.
You don't murder people.
At least Yisro had a more sensitive
conscious than the statesmen of today.
You let murderers who kill 35, 36
people, I mean, go free, I mean.
It has never happened in -- not
in our history, but in the
history of the world, yes.
And what did Iyov do?
Job? Shatak, kept quiet.
Right.
Then, he was bimei Mordechai
v'Esther b'Shushan Ha'Birah.
He could have protested against such
an edict that was issued by Haman.
"Laharog u'l'abed es kol
ha'Yehudim mi'naar v'ad zaken taf
v'nashim b'yom echad b'shloshah
asar l'Chodesh Adar." Why?
For what?
Did he protest?
No.
He was an individualist.
What did he do?
With what was he concerned?
How did he spend his life?
What troubled his mind?
Whom did he love?
He loved somebody; himself and his family.
And the pasuk tells us in
the most beautiful manner.
"And it
was so, when the days of their
feasting were gone every week,
that Job sent and sanctified them,
and rose up early in the morning,
and offered burning-offerings
according to the number of them all."
It means he did seven.
Beyond the Number 7,
no one else existed for Job.
A Jewish people didn't exist.
He forgot about it.
That's why he met with disaster.
It is quite characteristic that when
God rewarded Job and gave him everything
back, He stipulated one condition.
Job will find everything he lost.
In fact, he will get twice as much,
provided he will do just one thing.
Bildad Ha'Shuchi and Elifaz Ha'Teimani
and Tzofar Ha'Naamasi were in trouble
because they did not handle Job properly.
And God said that you forgive their
sins provided Job will pray for them.
But Job has never prayed for anyone
else but for himself and his children.
How can Job pray for somebody else?
Or he could perhaps come to
shul on Shabbos and make a
Mi Sh'beirach, like we do sometimes.
Yeah, but a Mi Sh'beirach
was not enough.
And God said, "L'hispallel baadchem,"
He meant real tefillah, genuine
prayer, genuine intersession,
but this was a condition Sine qua non.
And apparently, Job rose to great
heights after he met with disaster and
he found in himself enough love and
enough concern for others and enough
dedication that he indeed prayed for them.
And the pasuk tells us -- and this
is the whole moral of the Book of
Job -- "And the Lord changed the
fortune of Job, when he prayed for
his friends; and the Lord
gave Job twice as much."
A single existence is
quite often very dangerous.
It may lead to the disaster of Job.
It led to disaster, the single
existence of the American Jewish
community, during the Holocaust period.
We are all so concerned with ourselves.
We are not concerned with the world,
certainly not with our brethren
and our fellow Jews, and we let
millions of Jews go down the drain.
Somebody told me, and he's right, that to
the least of Al Cheits, of the chata'im
we enumerate on Yom Kippur, we should
add another Al Cheit, and perhaps it'd
be the worst, the most horrible one.
Al cheit sh'chatanu lefanecha
b'ra'inu tzaros nafshoseihem shel
acheinu Beis Yisrael sh'his'chanen
aleinu v'lo shamanu.
I raised the question
because -- I don't want to say it.
I'm afraid we are about to
confront the world again.
Not
-- you know what I mean.
We're isolated, completely alone,
the whole world is against us, be
it because of the shortage of oil,
be it because man is unreliable,
"Kol ha'adam kozev." I don't know.
Frankly I can't understand, I mean,
the leaders of the world today
and they are going to sell out.
I'm afraid so.
I'm not an alarmist by nature, but if
they are going to sell out, it will be a
problem for the American Jews how to act.
And I don't recommend
any course of action.
I don't know yet what's going to happen,
but I believe that every American
Jew should have this possibility
in mind, how we'll act like Job
before he met with disaster.
We are safe here.
Of course, as far as human
beings are concerned, you can
never stay safe in absolute
terms, you understand, but
shall we or will we support?
I mean, I don't mean support to give some
money, but more than that is involved.
I don't know.
I don't advise.
I don't suggest.
I don't give -- I am just
reminding you this is the problem.
Hence, Judaism, on the one hand,
understood the greatness of the
existential experience of man alone.
It's important to be an individual.
As I told you, man is creative because
he is an individual, because he's
different, because he can't be alone.
He can live in the recesses of his
personality, unknown to others and on
the other hand, Judaism also understood
the greatness of the community of the
existential experience of living in
the community or with the community.
And Yahadus said the thesis
plus the antithesis are correct.
Individual -- the Jew must be capable
of being alone and at the same time
being together, of withdrawing from
society, escaping from society, from
the noise of the street, from the
vulgarity, from the coarseness of
society, from the artificiality of
society and also must be capable to
come back and join society and merge
with society and be one with society.
The Jew should experience existence
as a "together" affair, as
well as an only "I" affair.
And the Jew should now the art of
being concerned only with himself
and also to say -- in the same
time of being concerned with all,
with the community.
The individual is both, a separated
existential entity who cannot
imagine existence outside of himself.
Let me be -- you know, when man
gets older, he begins to think
in very strange, peculiar terms.
I can imagine many things.
I cannot imagine one thing and
this is because I am an individual.
What world -- how is it possible for
the world -- will it be possible
for the world to go on existing
after I'll be gone?
I cannot imagine that.
I cannot imagine it.
There is a short story written by
a master writer, Peter Altenberg.
He was a Jew, assimilated Jew.
He was at the turn of the century.
He fought against Herzl because
Herzl also lived in Vienna.
He was the correspondent -- the
Parisian correspondent for the
Allgemeine Freie Presse, yeah.
So there is a short story, a
short story written by Altenberg.
It's called New Year, 1951, or '41.
Anyway, so he describes a New Year Eve.
The streets are blanketed with
snow and everybody is rushing and
He gives a -- he was a very sensitive
man, and he gives a portrayal
of New Year's Eve, as a Viennese, I mean.
You have to be in Vienna now
to understand what it means.
You understand.
As a Viennese, all the dances and the Prosit Neujahr, I mean,
and the kissing each other and
embracing each other.
And then there is the last line.
"The same New Year's Eve as I celebrated in 1903, what is the difference?
There's one difference only.
Peter Altenberg will not be around in 1951, on New Year's."
It means he couldn't imagine
how could a New Year's Eve take place
without him.
And this is typical, I mean, at
least, I mean, of many individuals.
We don't think in such terms, but
from time to time, thoughts converge
upon us -- converge.
And I -- of course, I don't
think in terms of New Year's Eve.
I think in terms of -- I think New
Year's Eve is -- the experience of
New Year's Eve is not a part of my,
let's say, fond memories.
I was once beaten up on New Year's Eve.
In Germany, I mean, in Germany, in
Furth, Germany, a bier German met me,
"Prosit Neujahr," and he beat me up.
It was 1933 or '32.
Anyway, so what I think many times,
you know, when such thoughts come
up on Yom Kippur and Rosh Hashanah,
I think of another Rosh Hashanah.
In the future.
And I see all this -- I see it in the beis
midrash and the same routine going through
their routine, na, na, na, and the chants
of the chazzan and the typical melodies,
"Halleluyah hallelu Kel b'kodsho,"
and there's, "Ha'Kel yeshuaseinu
v'ezraseinu selah," everything as it was.
But there's only one
difference; I won't be there.
And this is a tragic experience.
The individual cannot imagine
a world without him being
around, being a part of it.
And this is -- basically,
it's a tragic experience, but
it is a creative experience.
It’s an inspiring experience.
I can't explain it to you, but
it's inspiring and it is rooted in
the individuality and
exclusiveness of the human being.
And that's why when we recite Zichronot
on Rosh Hashanah, we speak, V'al
hamedinos bo yei'omer yomer eizo la'charev
v'eizo la'raav u'vriyus bo yepakeidu.
The community, as well as the individual,
are judged by the Almighty.
He looks upon the single person as
a part of a collective as well as a
closed-up being, as an open being in
steady communion with the community --
I mean, with the society and on the other
hand as a closed-up being, separate,
abiding in the shadows of community.
The same dialectical method, and I want
to emphasize it, is applicable to the
relationship between the covenantal
community -- I mean, the Jew and humanity.
What's our relationship to mankind?
Are we a part or aren't we a part
of mankind?
Antisemites now say no, the
Jew is not part of mankind.
This is the main trope, antisemitic
story now which has been circulating for
a long -- for quite a number of years.
The Jew is very clannish.
He's only concerned with himself.
Proof?
When the war broke out on
Yom Kippur, the Jewish community
raised a billion dollars in a few
days, but did the Jew raise money for
For Vietnam?
Was the Jew concerned
with the war in Vietnam?
Or was the Jew concerned with the
drought-stricken, I mean, Africa?
He's clannish, he's selfish.
Not as an individual.
As a group, they are selfish.
They are group-selfish.
There is group selfishness.
Let's ask ourselves, are
we a part or aren't we
a part?
We're a part of mankind because
all diseases which attack a
non-Jew can attack the Jew as well.
Yes, I mean, the same therapy, but
I mean experientially, spiritually;
do we belong or don't we belong?
I believe the answer lies in already
-- in the dialectical method we introduced
with regard to the old controversy.
What's the relationship between
the individual and community?
The individual belongs to the
community and doesn't belong.
He retreats, withdraws from the community
and then he joins the community.
The same is true of the covenantal
community versus universal community.
The covenantal community is also just
an individual and individuality.
We certainly share the concerns of
man, in general, because we face
the same problems, such as disease,
famine, injustice, et cetera, but at
the same time, we are also concerned
-- or we are concerned with ourselves.
We have interests and concerns of our
own and one is not supposed to drop our
concerns, our individual concerns because
so many say that the Jew is egotistic.
Again, we are part of humanity.
At the same time, we
are alone for ourselves.
Hence,
Judaism has another method by
which it sets up a festival and
by which it invests or it endows
this festival with meaningfulness.
It paradoxically is the fact that
the yom kavuah -- they called
Chanukah, Purim a yom kavuah.
There was no kedushas hayom in those days,
but a yom kavuah, there is
something specific,
something unique, something singular
to the day that the fact that the
yom kevuah represents philosophically
the antithesis of the Shabbat idea.
The latter, the Shabbat idea, stresses
human liberation from society.
Human withdraw from society.
A movement of recoil away from
society into one's individuality,
into one's own private world.
And Shabbat characterizes
or is representative
of complete immersion of the
individual in himself and
consequently in the Almighty as
a lonely being.
Yamim kevu'im emphasize
the opposite motif.
What does Yom Tov mean?
Yom kadosh,
semantically, simply if we'll
take Hebrew semantics, means what?
The holiday, what more -- I said
what holiday stands for in Hebrew.
A separate day, an isolated day,
a unique day, a singular day.
It means the day on which the
individual reaches out for
singularity, not for universality.
For uniqueness, for aloneness, from being
different, from being like -- not like
others, a day of self-immersion.
That means self-introspection,
inner-directedness, if I want to use a
colloquial term, a day of being alone.
This is kedushah.
Kedushah means being alone.
Kadosh Kadosh Kadosh, being remote.
What does Yom Tov mean?
What is Yom Tov?
What does that mean semantically?
Translation in English,
what does it mean, Yom Tov?
What does Yom Tov mean?
Might be -- tov in Hebrew has
actually two connotations.
Tov might be pleasant.
Pleasant.
We just read last Shabbos, "Tovas
mareh," doesn't mean Rivkah
was kind, but tovas mareh means
the appearance was pleasing.
Fine.
And then there is tov means kindness.
Whatever, I don't care, Yom Tov means
a day of kindness, a kind day or a
pleasant day, but pleasant and kindness
can only be imagined within society.
No one -- man in isolation
cannot be pleasant.
Pleasant to whom?
Man, no.
Can man, in isolation, be kind?
Kind to whom?
Robinson Crusoe could not be
kind, nor could he be pleasant.
It already describes a
certain relationship.
I am pleasant in my relationship
to others, but I cannot
be pleasant to myself.
Yom Tov, when we say,
represents the opposite idea of Shabbos.
It's a day of commonness, of mutual
participation, a day of tearing
down all fences, of erasing all
boundaries, of leveling off all
distinctiveness, separating man from man.
It's a day of sharing.
Not the individual but the
community is the hero of the day.
The merger of the individual
with the community.
On Shabbos, the individual
withdraws from the community
and on Yom Tov, a yom kavuah, the
individual unites with the community.
On Purim and Chanukah, there is no
issur melachah because issur melachah
represents a different idea, like I said.
However, there is a precept
of simchah v'hallel.
While issur melachah represents
the isolation
of the individual, as I explained before,
simchah v'hallel is indicative of the
union of individual and community.
There is no simchah halachically, unless there is sharing.
Whenever you say simchah halachically,
it means you rejoice but gladden
the hearts of others as well.
Make others rejoice.
That cannot be halachically.
I'm not speaking now in homiletics,
in terms of -- in homiletical terms.
I'm speaking in pure halachic terms.
There is no simchah
unless many are involved.
And if, for instance, something
happens which makes me happy,
why should someone else be happy?
So I have to try my best to
involve somebody, the thou
in my happiness, in my joy.
And I believe when I said -- I spoke last
time here, this a tradition as old as
our mother, Sarah, the one who initiated
that tradition, that simchah and sharing
are synonymous or identical is Sarah.
When she received the
greatest gift, Isaac.
“Tz'chok asah
li Elokim," God made me rejoice.
He bestowed upon me the most beautiful,
the most precious gift, but I can
only rejoice if kol ha'shomei'a
yitzchak li," that whoever will
hear the good news will rejoice
with me, otherwise there is no joy.
Interesting ideas.
The Gemara in Moed Katan calls simchah
"simchah d'rabim." Any kind of joy
must be shared by the multitude.
There is no simchah unless
there is sharing, unless one's
existence becomes suddenly
unbounded, open and all-embracing.
The Bible never fails to mention,
whenever it speaks of simchah, that
one has to share his blessings
with somebody else, "Atah u'vincha
u'vitecha v'avdecha va'amasecha
v'ha'ger asher bi'sharecha",
"Ki ein l'chelek v'nachalah
imach," make him rejoice.
The Megillah urges the people to
celebrate Purim by feasting and
sending gifts to acquaintances and, in
particularly, and presents to the poor.
On Chanukah, it's not the sharing
what he -- there is sharing on Purim.
It's a day of sharing.
As a matter of fact, the whole
institution of tzedakah on Purim
differs from the universal institution
of tzedakah the rest of the year.
There are basic differences.
For instance, you have social -- there
are many social workers here.
You know that mother and child cannot be
given just anyone who will ask for help.
You investigate.
Of course, in certain respects, we
agree with the mother in theory that
you investigate before you give.
However, on Purim, there
is no investigation.
"Kol ha'poshet yad," whoever stretches
out his hand should be given.
It's a different kind -- because
the day -- the essence of the
day expresses itself in sharing.
Chanukah is not sharing of
material goods, but there is
sharing of Hallel or of sharing in
the joy of the nes.
The Ner Chanukah is always kindled in
the doorway, not inside of the house.
Never.
You know, we don't kindle Ner
Chanukah in the doorway, so you do
it -- we light it on the windowsill.
Ner Chanukah has got to be seen.
If I raise the Ner Chanukah
above 20 amos, I mean, is
the -- so my action is worthless.
Why?
Because simchah v'hallel can only
be achieved if man is ready to share
whatever he has.
And particularly Chanukah and Purim actually represent one idea.
I told you the idea of the community,
the individual within the community,
not outside the community and
particularly, it represents what?
What?
Common destiny.
If the individual is in the community,
then he experiences common destiny.
Individual in the community is not
only a metaphysical, existential
term, it's a historical term.
When the individual is immersed in
the community, then he knows that
he's no exception to the rule.
If the community can suffer, so he also.
He is not like Job, who thought the
whole world is exposed, vulnerable, but
my children are not vulnerable because
every Sunday morning, I get up and I
bring seven burnt-offerings and they'll
be protected no matter what will happen
to the world or to the community.
Well, they didn't, though.
Suddenly, a tornado was unleashed
and the tornado has destroyed many
homes and among the many homes which
were destroyed by the tornado, in a
funny way, Job's home was among them.
So Chanukah and Purim in a yom kavuah
is b'reshus ha'rabim reigns supreme.
On Shabbos, b'reshus ha'yachid.
A common destiny of all is
the motto of the yom kavuah.
The individual is not hated.
The single Jew is not hated.
The community is the target of hatred,
but you cannot beat the community,
so you select the single Jew.
The community is the target
of hostility and persecution.
The individual cannot escape that destiny
and likewise, salvation, when
it comes, it includes many.
It's very seldom when salvation
comes just to one individual.
And if it does come, he should right
away share in his happiness with others.
This is yom kavuah.
There is no issur melachah.
On the contrary, work is
the symbol of cooperation.
There is matanos
l'evyonim, v'samachta atah.
Who?
There is a Vav hamechaber.
You, "and", that
is the symbol of Chanukah and Purim.
All that can be understood against a certain
theological background.
There are two possibilities
concerning God and man's relationship
within the realm of history.
It is almost taken for granted
That God uses man from time to time as
an instrument in order to execute or
to fulfill His inscrutable will.
[audio gap]
There are actually, I mean, not two
relationships between God and man but
three relationships.
God does not use man as the fulfiller or
executer of God's inscrutable will at all.
Sometimes God acts all
by Himself.
All by himself.
God does not use man as the fulfiller
and executer of God's inscrutable will.
God does everything by Himself.
God Himself decrees and
fulfills His own decree.
Man's role in such cases, in
such situations, equals zero.
Man has not been assigned any role.
In certain cases, man is not assigned
any role.
The initiative is God, and the
realization is His as well.
All man can do in such a case is
to watch, to admire and to adore.
What case is it?
Of course, there was no
man at all in creation.
Creation, which is celebrated on the
Sabbath, is an act which was completely
planned, devised and executed by
the Almighty.
There was no man.
Man was created on Friday
as the final being, the final product.
And Chazal ask, why on Friday?
Why wasn't man created on the first day?
So, because man -- if man were created on
the first day, he would claim partnership.
He would say that he was a
co-creator with the Almighty.
But anyway, creation is -- man
was not involved in creation.
God is the creator and
sustainer of the cosmos.
Man has no share in that power.
God -- there's another case.
God uses man
not for consummation
and execution of His will,
but for holding the message.
Man is used as a prophet.
He's not involved in God's
action, but he carries God's word.
He brings the good tidings to the people,
for who will say God engages in action.
He tells the people, the downtrodden
and the unfortunate ones to be
liberated by God, that God is
about to execute, I mean, His
promise, but he himself does not
participate in divine action.
He's not a partner.
Man acts as the shaliach, as
the messenger or angel of God.
He carries the instructions.
This role
was assigned to -- this was
the role of Moses.
He was the Navi,
but the drama, he did not act.
He was not the actor on
the historical stage.
The drama was fully
realized by the Almighty.
And that's the reason that on the night
of Passover we say, "Lo al yedei malach
v'lo al yedei shaliach ela Hakadosh Baruch Hu bichvodo u'v'atzmo."
Whom do we exclude
from the whole drama?
Moshe.
You know very well Moshe's name is not
mentioned on the night of Passover,
not mentioned -- not even once.
Sometimes, parenthetically in certain
texts, but it's just parenthetically.
It's absolute -- his
role -- because his role was not
of co-actor with God but as the
prophet of God, to bring the
message of redemption to the people.
Third, there is a third relationship, and
this is the most difficult relationship.
God lets man take the initiative.
He plans this -- man plans the struggle,
man fights for freedom, man engages in
action and whenever man engages in action,
the latter is costly and difficult.
And if
God tells man to engage in action,
so the action is very difficult,
as I said, and costly, and God
wants man to bring sacrifices.
God wants man to play
his part seriously,
as if the final outcome
depended upon man exclusively.
Man is allegedly the central figure.
Of course, God, of course, determines
the destiny and lets man either go under
in defeat or emerge victorious, but
however, man is responsible for that.
The struggle cannot be won
without human total involvement.
In such cases, God demands from
man heroic action, and heroic
action means sacrificial action.
As far as Yetzias Mitzrayim is concerned,
man was not involved in the event.
Man was informed and carried out some
assignments on behalf of the Almighty,
yet he did not precipitate the events.
He had no share in planning and
executing, therefore we proclaim at the
Seder, "V'ani v'lo acher."
That's it.
Now, we know why Shabbat and Yomim Tovim
prohibition against work was decreed
and on Chanukah and Purim, work is
permitted and man has to celebrate the
day by sharing, not by withdrawing.
Correct?
Yes.
Because Shabbos, particularly
Shabbos and also the holidays are
a memorial to Yetzias Mitzrayim.
All holidays are a memorial
to Yetzias Mitzrayim.
Man had no share the actual redemption.
Even Moses had no share in that.
It was planned -- not only creation
but even Yetzias Mitzrayim was
planned and executed by the Almighty.
Moshe was more or less the announcer
who brought the good tidings, but the
drama was played by Hakadosh Baruch Hu.
He wrote the script, the
play, He acted on the stage.
And as such, man has to withdraw from
society, from work, because by withdrawing
from society and by retreating from work,
he withdraws from his glory, from power.
He returns everything to God because
Shabbos creation and Yetzias Mitzrayim
means God's full mastery over the world.
Man is helpless and man cannot do
anything in order to accelerate the
fulfillment of his destiny in order
to bring about redemption sooner.
He can't do that.
However, Chanukah and Purim, very strange.
Purim is still a Biblical
holiday, more or less.
Chanukah is not a Biblical holiday at all.
I mean, there is no text to Chanukah.
As Chazal say, prophecy disappeared.
It's only there was just people were
inspired by Ruach Ha'Kodesh, yes.
And so, in such a situation, God calls
upon man to act, to plan, to take the
initiative and to fulfill and to realize.
I mean, man's role expresses itself in
total involvement with the community.
In the readiness to sacrifice, this
was true of Esther, it was
true of the Chashmona'im.
They sacrificed.
The nes happened later.
When the sacrifices were brought,
we know very well they engaged the
so-called Seleucids or the -- in battle
many times and if there is a battle,
people lose their lives, I mean.
Now we speak about the nitzchonos,
the victories of the Chashmona'im,
but before a victory is won, there are
many sacrifices over here.
And so, when -- an event in which
the community -- man is involved,
then it leads to a different kind
of celebration, not of celebrating
the event in loneliness, alone, but
on the contrary, in celebrating the
event by the individual who merges
with the community because altogether
made it possible, the nes possible.
And the symbol of the day is instead
of -- is not prohibition against work.
This engagement, on the
contrary, withdrawal of
the symbol of the day is coming as
close as possible to the community and
joining with the community and seeing
myself just a part, an integral part
of a great community with God, in
which God has completed [inaudible].
This is the difference between yamim
kedoshim, days of withdrawal
and yamim tovim, days of kindness or pleasantness.